hey we are live and in color we thank
you for joining us on Facebook live
where their Facebook live or CBS this
morning podcast I'm Gayle King and you
are safe and Reynolds what you mean to
say is best-selling author Jason
Reynolds Jason by the way has a new book
out it's called long way down it's
published by Athenian books which is an
input imprint of Simon & Schuster a
division of CBS but this is a thing
Jason on this day live Tuesday October
24th 2017 look what's on the front page
of the Washington Post Style section and
where is it located above this is a
really big deal I just want to say this
to you congratulations thank you Jason
Reynolds in case you weren't watching
CBS this morning which we hope is your
favorite morning show but just in case
you missed it yesterday we did a great
piece on Jason Reynolds where we
introduced you to the audience to talk
about long way down and what attracted
me to you is that you're this
best-selling author who's written
several books but you did not read your
first book cover-to-cover until you were
17 no no how is that possible why is
that possible well I'm you know at the
end of the day I think for me when I was
younger it it wasn't about the actual
reading process it was about the fact
that I didn't think that stories were
written for me right you talk about Moby
Dick I do I talk about Moby Dick and I
talk about how like it's really strange
that they would want me to read a book
like Moby Dick because a lot of the kids
in my neighborhood had never seen a
whale or boats or anything like that I
didn't seem applicable to my life they
didn't seem relatable to me I would have
rather it seems like their life stories
about kids growing up in my neighborhood
with sunflower seeds and ice cream
trucks and and things that we were
experiencing yeah you call it writing in
a natural voice yes internationally it
means that in every single era there is
a natural voice of that era specifically
when you break it down by cultures in my
time in the hip hop generation there's a
natural voice that we all have depending
upon where you're from it just so
happens that that natural voice everyone
said was improper right it's improper
English where for me it wasn't it didn't
feel improper for me it felt natural it
felt familiar uh-huh and so putting that
voice on the page was important for me
and you credit rap music yes for really
changing your life in time in turn
of how you looked at reading how you
looked at poetry when it comes to rap
music in particular I was surprised to
hear that you credit who Queen Latifah
the great great great Queen Latifah and
she's great because she's great for me
because she was the first cassette tape
I bought it was the beginning that's the
first one that I ever bought with my own
money and I read what was it it was
Black Rain which is the album that the
famous you and I do I know it's not you
and I it's you and ity that's why okay
so that was that was that out that was
that album
we get from that album I read the lyrics
I read the lyrics in the liner notes so
I didn't just listen to the album but I
read what she had written and I saw the
way the stanzas were broken down verse
by verse and I realized that Latifah and
then everybody in that generation right
there the teenagers by the way they were
kids teenagers that they were writing
this bring it poetry and that poetry is
what sort of it catalysed mean it in a
way and it started me on my path of
writing poetry in our piece you compare
it and I never thought about this but
you compared Queen Latifah yep to Maya
Angelou absolutely absolutely a thing I
mean you say that like yes Gale of
course I did hope I see the connection
well I think that if you if we look at
it if we take away this sort of
generational coding right what I mean by
that is and we talk about natural tongue
and we talk about the context I think if
you take through a context away what you
see is if you take a song like ladies
first
yeah take a song like phenomenal woman
the sentiment of those two pieces are
exactly the same this sort of an anthem
for women to say I am strong and you are
threatened you are threatened by my
strength and I'm not gonna apologize or
be made to feel small for being a strong
woman instead I'm going to beat my chest
and say you gonna have to deal with it
right either you get down or you go you
get rolled over right that kind of thing
and I like that I like and everybody go
back even further we see the same thing
before Maya Angelou we'd see it with
Phyllis Wheatley right like it this is
this is this is sort of a through line
in and poetry whether it's whether it's
called a rap music or not it's still a
through line and let's talk about rap
music you do it with finger quotes
because you know rap music and sometimes
take a hit as you know sure I happen to
like rap music but a lot of people say
that it's misogynists
yeah that it's violent yeah that is not
productive and to that you say what
about rap music I'd say listen to more
rap music listen to more because I'd say
I'd say do you work right do you do work
don't don't always take the easy way out
and I think that like is rap music
massaging it some of it is it violent
some of it is it complicated yes just
like me just like America like our
neighborhoods right it is all the things
rap music can can be comprised of every
emotion and every instance just like
every other kind of music so rap music
gets this sort of bad rap but every
music has a little bit of that in it
yeah right some good some bad some up
some down some complexity some nuance
it's just that our music so we've got
the bad hit for it but you're saying
don't paint it with one brush and we
encourage you and listeners to reach out
to us if you have a question for Jason
because you actually I hear like talking
to people I love talking to people
that's are them people that's what I
heard I heard that you like talking to
me also the other thing that pressed me
is that you have a very special
relationship with your mother number one
I love I would tell my favorite daughter
Kirby somebody who is good to their
mother and cares about their mother has
a good foundation yeah but you talk
about your mother quite often you have a
special relationship with her I do my
mom is sort of a cut above for me I
think she's cut from a very particular
cloth she's a woman who was born and
raised in South Carolina she moved to DC
when she was 10 years old and she's
worked her entire life I mean we're
talking about the age of 15 years old to
the age of 55 working non-stop in the
same company retires and then goes back
to work as a schoolteacher and has been
there for 13 or 14 likes acting career
right and I think for me what she gave
me what she gave me and my sibling that
she gave us 42 she taught us emotional
and mental fortitude no excuses you
stand up you get your work done you do
what you need to do that no excuses
because your mom we could I see my iPad
Dana
Dana's our producer of this piece
because we we interviewed your mom in
the piece yesterday and I know you have
a special relationship and I asked your
mom if she would join us on this
conversation I asked her if she so we
have this what happened here yeah okay
so I asked her if she would FaceTime on
okay so I'm trying to FaceTime call of
my mother yes yeah yeah that is
definitely my mother's name
see if I told her that we were trying to
call between 10:00 and 10:30 let's see
what she be doing let's see that work
where this good is let's see if my mom
knows how to work FaceTime there's the
real question this is probably doesn't
that's okay I wish he would though I
wish he would too because I want people
to see your mom and to see the
difference that she meant it just says
FaceTime FaceTime unavailable I know the
old lady and she she probably looked at
her phone and said I don't know what's
happening you know she probably thought
it was something was wrong about what
was wrong with the phone all right
I don't even know if she had FaceTime on
that phone but if she really my mother
don't get me started on that the other
thing that I thought was interesting
about your life is that you went to
University of Maryland I did and at
University of Maryland I'm thinking you
got in even though you hadn't written
the whole you hadn't read a whole book
right right and I said how were you able
to do that you said listen Gail there's
a sinkhole cliff note there there were
cliffs notes and and they were I mean
this part this is a part of the story
that is always I'm never happy about it
but it's the truth
and it wasn't just me I'm not an anomaly
in this way I think we were able to sort
of navigate education in a way that got
us by so I can add Cliff's Notes and you
would you know read the first couple
pages read the middle read the back half
and it sort of put it together using
context clues or you would speak vaguely
whenever the teachers asked you to sort
of write an essay about something you
just sort of give a broad brushstroke so
hopefully get a c-plus and you majored
in English at university I did and so
you tell a story about graduation day
which also sort of spurred you to say oh
I'm going to prove them wrong because
you're an English major I was an
Englishman here you are sitting on the
podium very proud day in your life
graduating and and the end the the
keynote speaker the commencement speaker
he said if you're getting a degree in
English you're gonna be a teacher or a
lawyer but you will not be a writer I'll
never forget it
said what I'm gonna show up all right
I'm gonna spend the rest of my life
trying to prove a man I'm never going to
see it getting wrong yeah well yeah I
will yeah yeah the name of the book is
long
to the book because I had asked your mom
if she would call in knowing that I know
she's technically challenging second but
we did record her so she did send up
video message so let's roll the bit yeah
let's roll the videotape we have to have
a backup just in case let's roll the
videotape control room here comes what
up Jason is slot-c phone wasn't good I'm
actually on the set of our TV show star
just outside the door but I just want to
take a minute to say peace it's nice to
meet you even though it's in a video but
since you're too shy to speak to me I
figured I would speak to you I think
you're incredible I love that my music
and lyrics were able to open up your
creativity and let you know that you
could do what you already knew you could
do and thank you for blessing the kids
with things that we can relate to I read
a lot of young adult books so I'm about
to die for your old catalogue I look
forward to meeting you one day I really
want to meet you brother in the meantime
stay up keep doing your thing and I'll
talk to you know so I wasn't really
calling your mom I was calling Queen
Latifah on the set and she said if I
could get away from filming cuz she's
filming right now if I could get away
from filming I'll take the call live if
not so she sent that tape as a backup so
I wasn't really calling your mother I
was calling
Queen Latifah cuz she said I really want
to talk to you I reached out to her
yesterday and I sent her the tape which
she did watch Marcy's hair is fellas she
did watch it yesterday not only did she
watch it she's already ordered your
whole catalog and she wants to read the
book long way down and I said wait till
you get to the end data that we must
discuss so you are definitely on her
radar screen shall we talk about long
way down so I just had to say I don't
know we had to talk about the book but
it's out the Queen Latifah I'm mom
I've waited a long time you know I just
wanted to I just wanted her to know
right that this is something that
mattered to me that this that her life
wish she had she her music that it
mattered to me and that it changed
people that she may never know that she
may never meet and then that changed
trickle
to a lot of other young people now whose
lives get to be different because of the
work that I'm trying to do search that
out so like see if I'm I can't wait to
one day meet you oh she really wants to
meet you and I guarantee you that's
gonna happen I guarantee you but I told
her that that she had come into a retail
store where you were working right and
that you were too shy to say anything
dude that's why she said since you
didn't see there she is someone you've
acquired and you don't walk up and say
hello I am NOT a very starstruck person
I'm not an excitable person as everybody
knows but for some reason when she came
in the store I couldn't I couldn't make
words I couldn't I couldn't you're a
writer mr. Reynolds oh but we also were
trained to not be that whenever said
lady come in with all these things
happening by the time I got the courage
to say something she'd already left the
store never to be seen again
no no that is gonna be seen because
she's gonna read this book and I predict
she's gonna love this book
long way down is the name of the book
and you tell the story in 60 seconds yes
what happens in these 60 seconds in 60
seconds a young man named will gets on
an elevator this is the day after his
brother has been murdered
and he gets on the elevator with his
brothers gun and he is intending to go
to the ground floor walk outside and and
take revenge on the person who he thinks
killed his brother and while on this
elevator he is met by several visitors
but this is it visitors from his past it
is from his past you are no longer alive
who are no longer alive but this is the
thing what you talk about the elevate
number one the way it's written it looks
like a bunch of poems yeah
put together but and each poem stands on
its own but you actually weave a story
it's so I like the writing style but you
said there's a strange thing about the
elevator everybody gets on they hit the
button blah blah blah blah but you say
they don't hear you read it they don't
see me read that part they don't speak
to the people already in the elevator
and the people already in the elevator
don't speak to the newcomer yeah that's
so true we all face the wall absolutely
said those are the elevator rules I
guess no talking no looking stand still
stare at the door and the door and wait
where did you get the premise of working
in the elevator though I thought that
was so interesting
well the elevator the elevator the thing
about this book is that everything
mimics this young man's mind so the
elevator the poetry it's all supposed to
be sort of siblings like it mimics sort
of his trauma his pain his anger and so
I talked about the elevator rules were
really talking about are the rules to
trauma the rules to pain right a steel
box it's cold it's empty it's a little
jagged it's a little rickety
there's vertigo involved that's what it
means to feel pain to feel anger at a
certain level yeah and and and with that
anger comes rules whether you're in an
elevator or whether you're in you're in
your psyche but this whole book is about
rules yeah the rules of the street so
let's let's talk about the rules
rule number one no crying okay no crying
right we later what happens no matter
what happens right direct connection to
toxic masculinity what does it mean to
be tough to be a man you cannot cry no
motion woo number two no wait do you cry
Jason as often as I can this is her this
is her thank you so much Queen Latifah
for calling what's happening I can't
believe it they tell you they tell you
how that one time you came in the ragam
bone and I couldn't speak to you came
and they're looking for sweatshirts it
was a ragam bone yes
and you came in and I was I was a little
stuck you know I apologized you know you
did you started reading oh good good
good I just wanted to tell you what I
got you here I just want to say I've
been waiting a long time to say this I
just wanted to say that that I'm
grateful that I'm grateful you know at
the end of the day I think that like we
make art and we do the best that we can
to make things that matter but the truth
is that you don't always know who they
matter to you know and I was a kid I was
like 10 years old when I read the lyrics
when I read I read all the lyrics of the
Black Rain album and it chemically
changed me
and I discovered poetry and from there I
I this all happened right like you were
a catalyst to the book you're holding in
your hand is part you is part yours
these thoughts and you just I guess the
hope ultimately is that somebody hears
you coming from to be able to inspire
you like that is just like that's the
you know my heart is it's like I can't
even say my is heavy and I said Queen
Lottie but you two will meet one day
right some bars I gained some balls when
I meet you
what a bard
[Laughter]
it's rapping Gail thank you thank you so
much for calling thank you thank you
thank you so much
these bees that's crazy I know losing my
black girl card because when I
interviewed when I interviewed Jason we
were talking about your look about your
dress yes yes and you said to me this is
all very deliberate of course this is
deliberate I looked the way I look as I
choose to write I walk into every space
and every space of that worker - I'd
like to say I sought the space right I
saw every space I walked into but there
are young people who need to know that
first of all they're young people who
look like me right tattoos and long hair
sneakers and all the things and those
intelligent have a lot to offer and they
should go absolutely don't judge and I
also walk into spaces where people are a
little nervous yeah and that's also okay
because I I can also debunk their
stereotypes and you got to have a
certain level of self-confidence to look
like this
and
I walk out of the house feeling good
about myself I know my mama loved me so
I'm alright we're looking at you falling
in love with you today Joe can I just
finish the last two rules of the book
because we did yes no snitches niching
and I always seek revenge and always
seek revenge those are the rules so the
crux of the book is what is will going
to do from the time he gets on the
elevator at the eighth floor
yep eighth floor down to the lobby it's
60 seconds he meets all these people
what at the end of the day is he going
to do and that's what you have to decide
when you read that book how does a book
end what is it a decision that will
makes yeah all I can say is Bravo bravo
Bravo I think you've taught us all a lot
I think you've taught us all a lot in
your creativity your intelligence and I
can't wait to see what you do in your
next chapter and I can't wait for you in
Queen Latifah thank you very much let me
hold it one more time long way down we
down on sale today wherever you like to
buy your books
bye